here in this video we will discuss about
the final fight of godzilla in singular
point
and how it was defeated by jet jaguar of
all the kaiju's
it was jet jaguar anyway we will discuss
what godzilla singular point really is
a little bit on the evolution patterns
of his and also look
into jet jaguar and its various upgrades
it is clearly a new take into the kaiju
universe with toho
being extra creative on the origins of
the monsters
and how mathematical formulas and the
flow of time intertwined into an
apocalyptic event that converges into
godzilla being the result of it all so
don't forget to subscribe to be a part
of the mind cue family
and now let's get down with this
sickness
to start with discussing the topic we
should know a little bit about the
strange new content of godzilla singular
point
and these are the mysterious archetypes
and the red dust
well one of the protagonists camino
suggested that
archetype is a trans-temporal structure
which means that half of it exists in
another dimension
another universe and the archetype is a
material that connects different worlds
and also maybe kaiju are also from
another dimension
they were brought to earth with the help
of the archetypes of the red dust
another thing was that the orthogonal
diagonalizer
was the 13th phase of the archetype it
functioned
as a catalyst to alter other archetypes
in simple words the orthogonal
diagonalizer
was the solution to the red does in a
kaiju catastrophe
in the notes of one of the characters of
the show ashihara
it was crippled that six is equal to
nine it was indicated that the archetype
could bend time space
laws of the universe and other things
creating an infinity structure
and another character called professor
lee called this phenomenon a singular
point
so let's start with the kaijus let's
start with the g-man
godzilla over the length of the series
transforms and evolves itself into
better versions
able to tackle the environment he is in
just as
in shin godzilla the singular point
kaiju also went through a series of
transformations
the first form we see was godzilla
aquaticus which was kind of a whale
slash mozasaur
like creature with a titanosaur
characteristics
and this creature was hundreds of feet
long and once it hits lan
under the red mist it transforms into
godzilla amphibia
and then successfully to terrestris
after coming out of a cocoon made of the
red dust itself
terrestris who had a form of an atomic
halo that it uses to fight of other
kaijus and humans then lastly we see
ultima the final form of godzilla in
singular point
featuring a more monstrous version of
his terrestrious form
with a deep charcoal coloration and
white dorsal plates
and the design also features an array of
jagged teeth
but the most peculiar thing about this
godzilla isn't the fact that he looks a
bit different
it isn't that he has a hunch posture
like dinosaurs
or the ability to evolve it is what he
really is
and what his origins are in all four of
his forms godzilla expels a large amount
of archetype from his skin known as the
red dust
in the form of a dense cloud around him
allowing him to cover and terraform the
surrounding area
with the red mist and it was said that
godzilla was in fact one of the main
singular points
the original point of the red does
archetype while godzilla can be killed
and die
from other factors he will always
manifest himself again
after his death and with improved
control over the red does
as he comes to understand our reality
better
now let's look into the other robot
kaiju well in the anime jet jagger was
named by its creator
called goro otaki and jajako has a
similar appearance and colour scheme to
the prior iterations of it
as well as the original signature grin
with rib
rubber connectors shielding the joints
perforated metal sheets covering the
cockpit
and three fingered hands that appear to
be borrowed from some industrial robots
it appears to be a mecca made by a small
scale constructor
jet jaguar's torso was written allowing
a human
pilot to be inside it ja jaguar also
possesses a cubicle backpack carrying
his main battery pack
which can be ejected during an emergency
and jai jago was seen in the beginning
of the series until the final fight with
godzilla
jet jaguar's responsiveness to kaiju
dangers had steadily
increased over the series and its
mobility has been altered with
two squat human legs being used at the
first time
well then being upgraded to a wheeled
tripod base developed by
industrial robots and lastly two longer
humanoid legs
and after this it uses the angular spear
as its main weapon
well it was kind of an angus scale stuck
into a pole so a spear
and during the penultimate episode it
was equipped with a helipad
sporting two large rotors attached to
its backpack so over the series the
first form was able to tackle
small rhodan the second form was able to
fight anguirus
and the third was able to fight off a
swarm of comongos
then the protocol to make jet jaguar
invincible transformed the robot into
one which is almost as tall as
godzilla's singular point
and rivaling the g-man in power so
despite its durability jet jaguar can be
damaged by sufficiently powerful attacks
which may require a lengthy rebuilding
period to return
it into a combat ready status and even
with the ultimate upgrade it was still
unable to withstand point-blank blasts
of godzilla ultima's atomic breath
despite its invincibility protocol
and massive growth and during the battle
jet jaguar and godzilla
got equal blows on each other and fought
almost to somewhat of a stalemate
but once the big g released his ultimate
power attack
the atomic breath the robot realizes
that the only way to defeat the big g
wasn't by
physical force since he was nigh
indestructible
and so with half of the face blown off
jet jaguar released
a mysterious code that activated the
archetype
the interdimensional molecule and with
that creating a chain reaction that
affected godzilla's molecules as well
exploding the g-man into blue crystals
and jet jaguar
getting destroyed as well in the process
but how did
jet jaguar manage to do this well the
protagonist
camino her artificial intelligence axis
shiva
the singular point monitoring and
controlling device and through that the
information
gathered the ai deciphered that using
the archetype it could stop the growth
of singular points
it also found out the codes for the
orthogonal diagonalizer
but before the ai could solve it a kaiju
called salunga attacked the facility
and so it failed to find the codes to
activate the orthogonal diagonalizer
but it found the answers to its
existence
and in the end the protagonist heard the
song a signal that was
heard since the beginning of the series
coming from the singular point
at irregular intervals and camino
concluded that the song
was a signal sent to the past from the
future thus everything was connected
to the song the ai sent the answer to a
protocol to make
jaguar invincible and with it jaguar was
able to access the code
to the orthogonal diagonalizer that
exploded and transformed godzilla into a
million blue crystals
and so with that we come to the end of
the video and that is how jet jaguar
managed to kill
the ultimate beast of all the king of
the monsters godzilla
while also losing its own life in the
process
so do like for support subscribe if you
haven't
to be a part of the minecube family and
also don't forget to click that bell
button for regular updates on new
monster content right here on minecube
but wait a minute do check out our other
videos
in the channel as we have quite a lot of
them and some of them you might have
missed out
since youtube can't suggest and
recommend all of our videos
so till the next one take care fam
you